[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الملف الاوكرانيه حيث اعلن
الجيش الاوكراني اسقاط سبعه صواريخ كروسيه
فوق العاصمه كييف وذلك قبيل ساعات من اصول
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انسوني الى
العاصمه في زياره غير معلنه تستغرق يومين
وسيشرب سلسله مباحثات مع عدد من المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين على راسهم الرئيس فولو دومير
زيلنسكي ونظيره ديميتروكوليبا القلم مسؤول
كبير بوزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه سيعلن على
الارجح حزمه جديده من المساعدات الامريكيه
لاوكرانيا تبلغ قيمتها اكثر من مليار
دولار
معنا من كييف مراسل الجزيره ايهاب العقدي
ايهاب حديثنا اكثر عن هذه الزياره لبلينكن
وكيف تتفاعل حولها حتى الان ردود الفعل
طبعا
المسؤولون هنا في كييف يتحدثون عن ان
المحادثات
ستبحث في مساله المرتبطه بتطورات السياسيه
المتعلقه بالحرب الروسيه مع اوكرانيا ايضا
المساعدات الامريكيه المرتقب وصولها الى
اوكرانيا لمساعده القوات الاوكرانيه في
هجومها المضاد الذي بدات بشنه قبل نحو
شهرين وتقول انها بدات بتحقيق اختراقات
على الجبهه وان عمليات القتال تتقدم في
تلك المنطقه
اعلن اكثر من مسؤول قبيله وصول وزير
الخارجيه الاوكراني ان مساله تامين السلاح
الضروري للقوات الاوكرانيه في هذه المرحله
خصوصا القذائف المضاده للدروع وايضا
الصواريخ المضاده للطائرات بالاضافه الى
اقتراب موعد وصول دبابات ابرمز الى
اوكرانيا والتي انهت اوكرانيا تدريب نحو
200 جندي على استخدامها على ارض المعركه
وهي جزء من حزمه للدبابات التي من المرتقب
ان تصل تباعا الى اوكرانيا لمساعده القوات
الاوكرانيه هناك طبعا لم يعلم بعد حتى
الان عن اجتماعات عقدها حتى اللحظه لكن من
المرتقب ان يعقد محادثات اهمها مع الرئيس
الاوكراني
وسيتحدث الى الصحافيين في نهايتها
الولايات المتحده كانت ايضا تراقب عن كثب
مساله الاصلاحات التي تقوم بها اوكرانيا
على مستوى مكافحه الفساد وذلك بعد اجراء
التعديلات على وزاره الدفاع وتعيين رستم
اميروف كوزير للدفاع الجديد بعد صدور
شبهات في وزاره الدفاع عن عمليات فساد في
تجهيزات الجيش الاوكراني طبعا هذه جزء من
ربما
المباحثات التي سيجريها ايضا بلينكن مع
المسؤولين هنا في كييف
شكرا لك ايهاب العقده مراسل الجزيره كنت
معنا